-[ Whispering ] Alright,
be really -- Alright.
Do you want to go get mommy now?
-I want to.
-Tell her we're shooting
the show.
Say, "We're shooting
the show, Mom."
-Mama?
-Yeah?
-We're taping the show.
-Winnie, are you gonna sing?
-Yeah.
Alright, is Franny
gonna hold the cake?
-Mm-hmm.
-Alright.
-♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
-Alright, grab the cake.
Get the cake.
Okay, perfect. Get the cake.
-Give it to me.
-There you go. Go.
-♪ Happy...♪
-You guys!
What?!
-Be careful, be careful.
-♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
-What?!
In trouble.
I love this!
-Finish. Sing it. Finish.
No, don't --
-Oh, wait.
We have to do some wishes.
Okay. Okay. Going in.
-Happy birthday!
We love you so much!
-Yay! I love you guys.
-We love you so much.
-Thank you. Mwah!
-Happy, happy, happy --
-Thank you.
I love you so much.
-And I love you, little ones.
♪♪
-♪ We in the house ♪
-Come on!
-Tonight, join Jimmy
and his guests...
Arnold Schwarzenegger...
Cole Sprouse...
musical guest Billy Corgan...
and the legendary Roots crew.
It's "The Tonight Show:
At Home Edition."
-♪ We in the house, y'all ♪
-And now, here's Jimmy.
-Hey, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show:
At Home Edition."
It's special day here, because
it is my wife's birthday!
The producer, camera operator,
location scouter, editor.
Yeah, we love you, honey.
And I know you don't like
surprises.
Oh, yeah. Don't worry about it.
You'll get
another cake later on, too.
But I won't tape that one.
I will say, I did --
My dad got you a gift.
-Stop it.
-Mm-hmm.
-[ Gasps ] No!
The best gift. No. Stop it.
Oh, my God! Graber Olives.
-My wife loves these olives.
-Best tradition in the world.
-Yeah. Right?
I guess my mom
started doing it, too.
-Yep, she did.
-Graber Olives is your favorite.
Why do you even -- They're good.
-Oh, don't! Don't speak.
-[ Laughing ] Don't speak.
-Unless you love them,
no right to opinion.
[ Both laugh ]
-I do love them.
But, anyways,
that's from my dad.
Happy birthday.
And, you know, I have gifts.
I have things for you
and all that stuff.
But I think you got
the best gift.
-I think I did.
-From --
-You can't even talk about it.
-I can't
even talk about it.
I'm so angry. Yeah.
Liza is awesome.
Yeah, but she knows --
She's a producer.
-She makes this show
that we love.
-Yes, called "The Challenge."
We love MTV's "The Challenge."
We are the biggest.
-Yeah.
-And is our favorite --
It has to be Bananas, right?
-Yeah.
-Without a doubt.
-I mean, not even --
-Yeah.
-We have others we love.
And there's others
we do not like.
-Yes, there are others we
dislike as much as we love --
-Some human that we look forward
to seeing every single time
is Johnny Bananas.
I think he is funny. I love him.
I've always liked him.
And, so, it's something --
But, anyways, you go,
"Dude, wait till you see this!
This is the best gift."
-I could not even teach today.
-For homeschooling? No.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you were so geeked out.
Our friend got Johnny Bananas to
do a personal message
for Nancy, for her birthday,
which is just untoppable.
Anyways, here it is.
-Alright, this is a very special
happy-birthday
shout-out going
to my girl, Nancy,
coming to you from
your boy, Bananas.
Nancy, may you live,
may you love,
and may your birthday
in quarantine
be absolutely bananas.
-Thank you, Johnny Bananas!
-Whoo-hoo!
-Come on! This is a lucky year.
-It is bananas.
-It's going to be a great year.
It's going to be a bananas year.
Thank you, Johnny Bananas. Gosh.
-Thank you, thank you.
-And happy,
happy birthday, honey.
I love you so much.
-I love you.
-I couldn't see you
from behind the camera, so...
Anyway, everybody, here we are.
This is Monday.
And I want to thank everybody
for staying at home
and for washing your hands
and wearing a mask
and doing all the right things.
I know some states have been
slowly opening, which is great.
And I want to say those states,
thank you
for not rubbing it in
to the states
that have to still stay home,
because we want to do this
the right way.
And it's baby steps
and it's small steps,
and for those states
that have to stay in lockdown,
we're going the get there.
And this is --
The hill is already over.
We're over the hill.
We're coming down.
This is like --
This time is just
be safe and do it right,
get tested.
There's lots of
testing out there.
If you can't get tested,
complain to someone.
I'm sure there's someone
that can do something
and get you all tested
so we all can move forward.
And I think I can see a light
at the end of
the tunnel here, guys.
But thank you, everybody,
for doing what you're doing.
I know it feels like no one
is thanking you, probably.
And it's probably 'cause
no one really is.
But I am saying thank you
on behalf of my family --
my wife and my kids.
Thank you so much for doing what
you can to -- I don't know.
It's a tough thing.
This is rough.
But, you know, we're all doing
it together, right?
In experiencing this stuff.
So I like to support
whenever I can.
Anyway, thank you
for doing that.
And thank you for supporting me
and watching the show.
Thank you, NBC, for airing this.
YouTube. Who else?
-Thank you, thank you,
Johnny Bananas.
-Johnny Bananas --
thank him again.
Graber Olives, we want to thank.
-Yeah.
-Fudgie the Whale
making a cameo.
Fudgie the Whale making a cameo,
straight out of Carvel.
Alright, here we go.
Guys, here's some
potentially great news.
Scientists working on
the coronavirus vaccine
announced positive results
in an early trial.
It's exciting.
From here, the vaccine will go
through the blind auditions,
the battle rounds,
and then it does well there,
it's going to Hollywood!
During his briefing yesterday,
New York governor Andrew Cuomo
got a coronavirus test
live on TV
to show that it's no big deal.
That's right --
they did the nasal swab,
and he said it was totally fine.
Although, for the rest
of the briefing,
he did speak with a
British accent.
[ British accent ]
New Yorkers are tough.
New Yorkers
have to stay together.
[ Normal voice ]
Today, Governor Cuomo said
New York sports teams should
plan to reopen without fans.
It will be so quiet,
the only sounds you'll hear
are the crack of the bat,
the pop of the glove,
and the adjusting of
testicles rattling inside a cup.
Come on. Come on.
This weekend, during an
interview with Jeanine Pirro,
Eric trump accused Democrats of
milking coronavirus lockdowns
to win the November election.
Jeanine Pirro was like, "Yeah,
I totally agree with you.
It's definitely a hoax.
Which is why we're doing
this interview
from the basement of our homes."
Some TV news.
The last two episodes of
Michael Jordan's --
Oh, gosh.
This happens to me all the time.
The last two episodes
were last Sunday's.
I do this all the time.
-Mm-hmm.
-Do you remember the biggest
game in the world? Game 5?
It was, like, LeBron.
Everyone talked about
his best game ever?
And I missed it because I
watched "Driving Miss Daisy"?
-Oh, yeah, that's right.
-No one e-mails me.
I don't have any sports friends.
The world watched it.
They said it's the best game
they ever seen in their life.
They could make an
ESPN docu-series of that.
I missed that because I go,
"You know what?"
Oh, maybe you were here
or something.
You weren't at the apartment.
I go, "I got a night to myself.
I've never seen
'Driving Miss Daisy.'
I heard it's good."
It is great, by the way.
Fantastic.
-It was a great movie.
-Yeah.
-Mm-hmm.
-Was Patti LuPone in there?
Make a little cameo in there?
Maybe?
It was a great movie, though.
Dan Aykroyd, props.
Anyways, loved the movie.
Missed the best game in
the history of basketball.
Anyway, so, I missed
the Jordan thing last night.
I watched Spade's movie.
But, hey, I got time.
I have nothing but time, right?
-There's always tonight.
-Well, tonight,
it's birthday time.
Just tomorrow.
-So "Dateline" it is.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, gosh.
I can't watch "Dateline"
before I go to bed.
Anyways, sorry. TV news.
Last two episodes of the
Michael Jordan docu-series
"The Last Dance"
aired last night.
That's right.
There was a lot of
unexpected moments,
especially at the end,
when Jordan was caught
on a live mic in the bathroom
confessing to three murders.
"I did it."
That's a little
"Jinx" reference.
Little "Jinx" reference.
Timely.
Our monologue, you know,
sometimes is not necessarily
the funniest thing
you've ever heard,
but boy, oh, boy, is it topical.
You know?
A little "Jinx" reference.
In the documentary, Jordan
revealed that in his
legendary flu game,
he actually had food poisoning
from eating an entire bad pizza.
Yep, the food poisoning
was really rough on Jordan.
Here he was before
the bad pizza.
And here he is after.
Come on. Papa John!
Everyone is talking about this.
Over the weekend,
Nelly and Ludacris tried to go
head-to-head on Instagram Live,
but Nelly's Wi-Fi was bad,
so he kept cutting out.
It was like listening to a
Lil Wayne song on Radio Disney.
♪ I'm gonna...you up ♪
♪ Then...your...face ♪
Wow. That's right --
the Wi-Fi issues
were really frustrating
for fans.
When Nelly got cut off,
they were like,
"It's getting hot in where?
What? It's getting hot where?
It's getting hot in..."
I saw that Graceland is
reopening this week.
That's cool.
When they heard that,
tourists were like,
"After sitting on my couch
for two months,
I want to see where Elvis sat on
the couch for three years."
I read that some states,
like Hawaii,
are asking tourists --
I love this.
Some states, like Hawaii,
are asking tourists
to help them handle
the coronavirus outbreak
by not visiting.
That's right -- after years of
trying to attract visitors,
now they're hoping
to keep them away.
A few states even unveiled some
new tourism slogans.
Check it out. First, Colorado.
Their slogan is, "You can buy
weed everywhere else now, too."
Next up, North Carolina.
Their new slogan is, "Trust us,
South Carolina is way nicer."
Then there's South Carolina.
Their new slogan is,
"No, no, no.
North Carolina is
by far the best."
Then there's New Jersey.
Their new slogan is,
"Get outta here!"
Next is Minnesota.
Their slogan is, "It takes
40 hours to drive here
no matter where you leave from."
That will deter tourists.
And, finally, there's
Washington, who says,
"We're basically
Canada's armpit."
Well, that will keep
tourists away.
Well, listen to this.
A new study found that
Jonah Hill
has cursed in movies
more than any other film actor.
Yeah, at 376 curses,
Jonah slightly edged out
Samuel L. Jackson
and Dame Maggie Smith.
Congratulations, Jonah.
I read about a new line
of nail polish
that smells like taco, pizza,
and cheese puffs.
Meanwhile, Americans are like,
"We've been quarantined
for over two months.
Our fingers already smell like
tacos, pizza, and cheese puffs."
And, finally, a man in
North Carolina just won
$10 million on
a scratch-off ticket
and said once
the pandemic is over,
he's taking his family
on a cruise.
When they heard,
his family grabbed his ticket
and ripped it up.
What's wrong with that man?
That is our monologue,
everybody.
Thank you very much.